The framework vendors however had made some
design decisions that differentiate their approaches.
For example, they often differ on memory management.
Java and CLR provide garbage collection, COM provides reference counting, and
CORBA doesn't provide anything at all.
As far as container managed persistence is concerned,
Java has Enterprise Java Beans.
CORBA has CCM, but CLR and Compost don't provide anything.
The vendors also have various approaches for the versioning,
some of them freeze, some of them have version numbers, some of them have
compatibility rules, and some of them allow for side-by-side execution.
Some other differences include the target environment for
the component frameworks.
J2EE and COM target servers.
COM also targets client and
desktop machines, whereas CORBA targets legacy applications.
They all also differ in terms of their development environments.
J(2)EE uses WebSphere, which is the commercial version of Eclipse.
And .NET uses Visual Studio .NET.
As far as protocols are concerned, Java and CORBA support IIOP and XML.
Java supports, also supports RMI.
COM and CLR support DCOM.
And CLR supports XML and SOAP.